the holiday season can be ludicrous
although this year it's doubly true
because Disney plus is releasing dashing
through the snow a holiday movie
Spectacular starring you guessed it
Chris ludicrous Bridges the rapper SL
actor is joined by Lil R howy and a
great Supporting Cast to give us a new
and hilarious looking take on the tale
of Santa Claus magically showing up in
real life so I thought I'd get in the
Christmas spirit and go through what we
know so far about this upcoming holiday
romp so what's dashing through the snow
all about well like all good Christmas
movies it has a character who has
decided that Christmas isn't for them
and while our protagonist isn't at
Grinch level of hate when it comes to
the holiday he's definitely not looking
to Carol around and trim a tree anytime
soon Chris Bridges whom I really want to
refer to as Luda but I won't in the name
of professionalism plays Eddie Garrick